[Music]
please what's the status a latin
superstar maluma calling out selena
gomez last year you made all of us go
crazy when you and Selena Gomez followed
each other and you put it out into the
universe that you wanted to do a song
with her what is the status can we get
that song yeah we were in touch but I
told her that I wanted to work with her
and I don't know why the things just got
freest but it would be a pleasure to to
have the opportunity to who's still on
the list I know that you're obsessed
with Justin Timberlake yeah when I met
Justin Timberlake in New York I almost
died you know about my music you knew
about my movement I love Bruno Mars I
love Ariana Grande Justin Bieber fingers
crossed for collabs with those big names
when maluma drops his English language
crossover album Fame later this year but
at 24 the Colombian singer has already
teamed up with plenty of huge stars and
he's hoping they'll show up on his
upcoming US Fame tour kicking off March
23rd you've collaborated with the best
of the best Ricky Martin Chiquita Marc
Anthony can we expect any of them to pop
up at certain dates
I'm working on it this is not easy
Margie's one of my best friends I
thought I'm never gonna have fine like
friends in the music industry and I can
tell Marc is one of my best friends I'm
gonna Taylor kita and let's see if we
can why I want to be part today your
maluma you pull out the phone you're not
the on speed dial
yeah we can't wait for you brother
please stop feeding your children please
come here what happened with over 50
million social media followers there's
no denying maluma a sweet Caliente I
never look myself in the mirror I'm
gonna like wow you know I'm 69 I never
say that you know I'm a normal person
you know I
love playing soccer I love working out
proving he really is just like us he's
also a huge keeping up with the
kardashians fan why is it your favorite
show tell me why you love it so much
he's like we have something in common so
every time I see them on in the screen
and like oh my god I live something like
that last week or and I cannot lie
they're beautiful although they are
beautiful and also that's that's why I
like the show I mean am I gonna lie you
need to do a song with Kanye now
Kanye become the phone I already call
breaking mine
[Music]